this afternoon metro police are still
piecing together a deadly shooting from
early this morning one person was killed
but detectives think the altercation may
have been self-defense
Hector Mejia live with the scene near
Tropicana and Fort Apache with the
latest hector one person is still on the
run police believe he was with the man
officers found murdered right behind
this in-and-out drive-through which is
now back open for business and metro
police believe this homicide may be the
result of self-defense just before 2:00
a.m. they tell us multiple people called
911 a gun battle broke out at in and
outs parking lot
officers say the surviving shooter is a
customer who immediately called him he
said he was eating outside not far from
the drive-through when he was approached
by two men
an altercation escalated to a shooting
between both groups more than a dozen
gunshots sprayed across the parking lot
one man in his 40s is dead the customer
was in custody but not under arrest a
motive for the initial confrontation is
still under investigation
don't know what led up to the shooting
the there was a female who arrived on
scene prior to the police arriving who
is the girlfriend of the deceased that
female moved the gun that the deceased
had and put that in her car
detectives processed that car in the
man's apartment he lived nearby some of
the businesses out here are left with
bullet holes officers also discovered
that a gun store silver bullet had its
windows shattered with rocks overnight
just yards away from the crime scene
they're still investigating whether or
not it's related to the murder since
this morning though they did determine
no one made entry into that gun store
and a bus driver who was on her route at
the time of the shooting shared with me
that she actually heard the gunshots and
she's feeling okay and thankful that
everyone around in the area is doing ok
as far as the people involved well we're
told by police none of their names have
been released yet
reporting from Torrey Pines reporting
near Tropicana and Fort Apache
Hector Mejia 8 news now